when I was selling copiers door-to-door
I had a very clear vision of what my
life was going to be like so many people
don't take risks for fear of failure
they don't start the business they don't
go create the art they want to create or
they don't go try out to be in the play
I don't subscribe to the fact that you
have to act serious to be taken
seriously
Oh
leave motivation what a top 10 with
belief nation hates Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to
trust your gut redefine failure and
manifest your ideas with Sara Blakely
and my take on her top 50 rules for
success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one trust your gut and then trust your
gut it's so important to trust your gut
you know I saw a man speak one time and
he said I'll prove to you in four words
there's no such thing as a bad idea and
he said Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
haha so I'm here today to prove to you
in two words there's no such thing as a
bad idea and that's footless pantyhose
so no matter what your ideas are you're
doing something better than your
competitors that's why you're in
business you've thought of an idea
that's why you're here and and then be
prepared for the opportunity number two
differentiate yourself one of the
biggest things I can say is
differentiate yourself and be obsessive
about it you know like tell tell
yourself in the mirror be able to tell
anyone in 30 seconds or less why you're
different
why what's out there isn't as good and
why the customer needs it like what is
the benefit to the customer number three
embrace failure I had always wanted to
be a lawyer and I basically failed the
LSAT I'm a terrible test taker and that
was a devastating moment for me but what
I quickly realized was that failure is
nothing more than life's way of nudging
you and letting you know you're a little
bit off course and Spanx would not exist
if I had not failed or basically found
the elf that I also was raised by my
parents my dad had
thing that he did when we were little
and it made me realize that I'm really
not afraid to fail at all my biggest
fear would be to not try something and
my dad when we were young my brother and
me we'd sit at the dining room table at
night and he would say what did you guys
fail at this week and if we didn't have
something he'd be basically disappointed
and it was complete reverse psychology
but it was brilliant because it caused
my brother and me to try out for things
we didn't think we'd be good at and it
made us less fearful to go outside of
our comfort zone meaning before
visualize I've visualized this for
myself when I was selling copiers
door-to-door I had a very clear vision
of what my life was gonna be like and I
encourage everyone to do it take a snap
photo of what success looks like for you
are you how many employees do you have
how much are you making where do you
live what are you sitting at a table
with world leaders are you standing on a
stage in New York City giving a speech
and hold on to that that snapshot and
you will subconsciously start to make
decisions that get you there and so my
snap photo for myself when I was going
door-to-door to sell copiers was to be
self-employed invent a product that I
could sell to lots of people and not
just one copier to each person and
create a business for myself that would
continue to fund itself if I wasn't
present I wanted money to be generated
without me having to be there I was that
specific in my vision also if you want
to learn from other successful women
entrepreneurs check out my 2:54 girlboss
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below when I was selling
copiers door-to-door I had a very clear
vision of what my life was gonna be like
from day one I just I never tried to
hide that I was the girl in my apartment
with the red backpack rule number five
be honest I think customers want to be
talked to and not talked to at and I
think a lot of companies talk at a
customer and it's very sort of glossy
and it doesn't seem real and from day
one I just I never tried to hide that I
was the girl in my apartment with the
red backpack it's like this is Who I am
and I find that people end up rooting
for you and opening more doors if you're
really honest early on some people start
businesses and try to come across that
they're much bigger than they are
because they feel like that's the only
way they're gonna be taken seriously but
if you know your products great and you
know why you made it you don't have to
apologize for being out of your home or
your apartment or being small rule
number six embraced not knowing I like
to say that the big secret behind
disruption is not having any idea how
it's supposed to be done I had no idea
how it was supposed to be done and if
you have no idea how something's
supposed to be done I guarantee you you
will end up being disruptive but the key
is you have to let it you know you have
to embrace not knowing all a lot of
times when we don't know something
especially you know most people in
society we end up being afraid of what
we don't know or we take that as a
negative
it can hold us back whereas if you let
what you don't know become your greatest
asset you are bound to do things very
differently because we're all mostly on
autopilot in life and if you think about
it we're doing things exactly the way
somebody else showed us how to do it
everything that we're doing is because
someone else showed us how to do it so I
like to do this mental exercise and I
tell people it's thanks to do it too I
say close your eyes and pretend like you
have no idea how to do your job just sit
in that space for a minute what comes up
if no one has shown you how to do your
job how would you be doing it and
listening to the answers but it takes
asking those questions asking why and
spending that time in that space to say
is there a better way what why has a bra
always been made this way or why why is
it this way and so for me my not knowing
was really a great asset for me rule
number seven right
down your goals if you write your goals
down it makes all the difference Harvard
did a study in 1973 they took the
graduating class and asked how many of
them had goals 100 percent of them had
goals well they asked how many had
written down their goals upon graduation
only 5% of the class had in 1993 20
years later they followed up with the
class they found that the 5% that had
written down their goals 20 years prior
upon graduating were worth more
financially than the other 95% of the
class put together so I have always
written my goals down about what I
wanted to achieve and I really attribute
a lot to that rule number eight higher
your weaknesses we say as soon as you
can afford to hire your weaknesses or
the things you don't enjoy as much do it
and anytime that you can delegate and
clone yourself kind of and try to get
some additional support it's a crazy
moment in a small business you know I
hired my day-to-day CEO about two years
into starting Spanx and up until that
point you know when you have no money or
every department so I got to learn very
quickly what I'm really better at what
I'm not as good at what I enjoy doing
what I don't enjoy doing and I couldn't
wait to hire someone to do fill in my
weaknesses and just focus on my
strengths
rule number nine think outside the box
banks is in all the top retail stores I
meet people all the time that say how in
the world did you get into Neiman's and
Saks and I say I called them and they
just look at me they said well didn't
you go to trade shows I'm going to trade
shows for seven years hoping that a
Neiman's buyer walks by I didn't know
enough to do that and it ended up being
a blessing so I always encourage people
to think outside of the box
the way it's always been done isn't
necessarily the way it should be done
and oftentimes what's inside of you
is a better way of going about it rule
number 10 think big in the next decade I
see things going worldwide everywhere
know
but left behind it's going to be all
over the world and it will become a
aspirational brand that transcends
categories were already transcending age
or now into men's so I really see
there's so many things we can improve
upon or make better and that's the true
inspiration behind the brands bank
rule number 11 redefine failure growing
up my father used to ask my brother and
me what we had failed at at the dinner
table which was so interesting and he'd
celebrate it and he'd actually be
disappointed if I didn't have something
that I failed at that week so I can
remember saying dad dad I tried out for
this and I was horrible and he would
actually high-five me and say
congratulations way to go and what it
did was just reframe my dish definition
of failure failure for me became not
trying versus the outcome so so many
people don't take risks for fear of
failure they don't start the business
they don't go create the art they want
to create or they don't go try out to be
in the play or whatever it is for the
fear of failure
and once you redefine that for yourself
and realize the failure is just not
trying then life opens up to you in many
ways and I would also my dad would
encourage me anytime something didn't go
the way I expected it to or maybe I got
embarrassed by a situation to write down
where the hidden gifts were and what I
got out of it and I started realizing
and everything there was some amazing
nugget that I wouldn't have wanted to
pass up rule number 12 believe you
famously started Spanx with $5,000 in
your bank account what was the hardest
part about getting Spanx off the ground
the hardest part about getting things
off the ground was definitely in the
very beginning when you have when you
first have an idea as an inventor and
you thought of something that doesn't
exist and you want to bring it into the
world there were two things that were
happening one was my own self-doubt was
a really hard part of the journey and
and then the beginning of all the
manufacturers that I was having to cold
call and talk to to try to get my
product made we're all men and it was
much harder to explain and to try to get
them to understand the concept of what
the product was so I heard
no for two straight years trying to get
it made which then increases the
self-doubt that can happen and one of
the interesting things about being an
inventor is you don't go to school for
it there isn't an inventor class
you can't major in inventing and so it's
really a belief system in yourself and
the willingness to look stupid or to
have people laugh at you or to fail at
something that you believe in your your
own gut check on that and so it takes a
lot of confidence so that was that was
the hardest part of my journey there was
a lot of starting and stopping and like
am I crazy and everyone's saying no and
but I you know I kept picking myself
back up to pursue it rule number 13
manifests your idea
I actually really manifested the idea so
you know it's like everyone's always
like how did you take an idea and then
start a business well it's how did you
even come up with the idea you know I
was in search of my idea and at the time
my life was not great I was selling fax
machines door-to-door I was living with
my mom I was like 25 years old and I
remember after a whole entire day of
being kicked out of office complexes
again all day or sometimes my business
card ripped up in my face I pulled off
the side of the road one day Kathy and I
was like I'm in the wrong movie like
what just happened but Paul the director
called the producer this is not my life
this is not my movie and I went home
that night I wrote down my strengths or
what I thought I was good at and the
only thing good column really was sales
and I thought okay well I know I'm good
at selling what is it I like about
selling and I realized I liked offering
something to someone that they need or
didn't know that they needed that can
improve their life or help them and so
in that moment I wrote down in my
journal I want to invent a product that
I can sell to millions of people that
will make them feel good and
[Applause]
and you know what and two years later
the idea came to me and and I was ready
for it you know people women had been
cutting the feet out of their pantyhose
for a long time and I only did it one
time but I had already asked the
universe for my idea and I said when it
comes I will not squander it and I will
take it and run with it
rule number 14 be courageous my dream is
for there to be many more female
inventors I'm hoping more and more women
will have the courage to take that risk
it's a risk to invent something you have
to risk being made fun of you have to
risk looking like an idiot you have to
do something that didn't already exist
which is scary
I mean my brain told me a million times
who do you think you are coming up with
this then one day you wake up and you go
well what if it is me remember 15 start
small think big thanks was profitable
from the first month that I was in
business and I I'm in of the belief
system for me in my journey to start
small think big and scale fast and a lot
of people want to start big and think
big and oftentimes get ahead of
themselves and and that can end wildly
successfully but it can also cause a lot
of problems and you dilute yourself down
a lot and you know then you have a lot
of other people you're answering to so
that just was the journey that I took
you know I mean is I started it with
five grand I've never had any outside
funding and whatever money I made from
selling Spanx I just put back into the
business I love that start small think
big number sixteen get off the autopilot
one of the things I also do is I like to
go up to people at Spanx and I say I'm
always trying to get people off
autopilot like if you think about it
everything we do almost everything we do
in life is autopilot we're doing things
exactly the way someone else showed us
how to do it or taught us how to do it
well if you're doing things exactly the
way everyone else is there's no there's
not going to be any real significant
change there's not going to be a really
meaningful potential breakthrough so I
always go up to people at Sphinx and say
if nobody showed you how to do your job
how would you be doing it
and I'll say just sit with that you know
I'm always like I'll stop myself often
and just say okay you know this is how
I've been doing it but is this right and
give yourself the time to think about it
so I ask people to do that number 17
start with why the best advice I would
give a female founder looking to launch
a female centric company or product is
to start with the why and continue to
lead with why and be very authentic in
your message stay vulnerable be yourself
through the process at Spanx when I
first started it I observed how
companies were treating me as a consumer
and I was very determined to be one of
my customers and to be authentically
connected to them rule number 18 hire
your weaknesses in the early days I mean
as an entrepreneur you're every
department so I was the before and after
but model literally I took a picture of
my own but took it to Kinkos got it
laminated with and without Spanx on
stood in the stores and I'm like hey
look what this can do for you I was I
was like the packer and shipper I was
the head of sales I was everything and
you learned very quickly what you're
good at and what you're not good at and
what you enjoy and what you don't enjoy
and there's usually a correlation
between the two and so I often say as
soon as you can afford to hire your
weaknesses and a few years into Spanx it
was abundantly clear that the lane that
I needed to stay in was inventing
selling promoting Spanx actually has
never advertised Spanx is 18 years old
and the first time we've ever even
sampled an ad was to in 16 and so I was
sort of the the advertisement and and me
being out in the field talking about the
product and sharing the story of the why
why we're making this why it's better
was a big part of the formula and I
needed someone to be in the company
day-to-day running the daily operations
rule number 19 solve a problem you were
a frustrated consumer I was and you
decided to try to solve a problem what
was the problem you were trying to solve
well I couldn't figure out what to wear
under white pants and I was a frustrated
the undergarment options at that time
were not great right we had underwear
that left a panty line shape girdles
that were really thick and uncomfortable
and then they invented the song which
just put underwear exactly where we've
been trying to get it out of so I was
like yeah I know and listen at the time
that I invented Spanx and for the guys
in the audience serve some of the ladies
who don't know what Spanx is it's just I
invented an undergarment that filled the
gap between traditional underwear and
those heavy-duty shapers and I was
interested in giving women a smooth
canvas like I love clothes I love you
know to be able to wear them but just
like a painter if you don't have the
right canvas it affects the whole
painting and the options weren't great
and they could be seen they left lines
they left bulges so that's what caused
me to to invent the first product which
was the first ever Spanx the footless
pantyhose you number-20 focus on impact
I would say for the next hundred years I
think entrepreneurs and business people
should be considering two things one is
the social impact I'm really thrilled to
see that businesses are really having a
social conscious and what they're
producing and how they're producing it
but also a much more feminine approach
to business I think that business
traditionally been very masculine in the
way that it's been done and I went about
Spanx in such a feminine way with much
more feminine principles and I think
when that's more balanced on the planet
we're all gonna be better off
rule number 21 manifest your idea I
wanted to be a lawyer and I'm a terrible
test taker after I basically bombed the
LSAT I he tried out at Disney World to
be goofy and you have to be 5/8 and I'm
only five six so I'm the height of a
chipmunk which was like I guess you
could say sort of felt a little bit like
rock bottom I wasn't gonna be a lawyer
and I was too short to be goofy there
was a moment when I was selling fax
machines door to door and I was
constantly being escorted out of
buildings or sometimes people would rip
up my business card in my face which was
a typical occurrence and one day I
pulled off the side of the road and I
literally thought I'm in the wrong movie
like this is not my life cut called a
director called the producer how did
this happen this is not supposed to be
my life I went home that day and wrote
at in my apartment in my notebook what
my strengths were and the only thing
basically in the strengths call him that
I was sure about was sales and I said
okay and what can I do with that and I
ended up writing I want to invent a
product that I can sell to millions of
people that will make them feel better
and it was two years later that I cut
the feed out of control top pantyhose to
wear white pants to a party rule number
20 to test a different approach I think
that there's there's you know
traditional business has been very
masculine and it's been a very masculine
model and so I approached it I mean and
when I say that I when I first started
Spanx I was maybe three months in and I
was at a cocktail party and I these
three guys came up to me and they said
Sarah so we heard you invented something
and I said yes I did and they said great
and one guy you know pat me on the
shoulder and he said I hope you're ready
to go to war and he said business is war
and I just remember looking at him and
thinking why and I went home that night
and sat in my
apartment and I sat on the floor and I
was thinking about all that was
happening and you know this risk I was
taking and potentially leaving my debt
job and that secure income and and just
thinking I don't want to go to war and
this voice inside of my head just said
do it different like take a totally
different approach and so I have
approached Spanx with very feminine
principles and there's there's the
feminine and the masculine in all of us
and it's all super important but you
know using vulnerability really
operating off of intuition if the data
is trumping my intuition I go with my
intuition almost every time so you know
that's not typical in in a corporate
environment so those kinds of things
that I've done like being vulnerable
with the business I am I felt as a
consumer I I just felt like companies
aren't really talking to me the way that
I want them to talk to me I know I'm not
listening to them I don't believe them I
don't necessarily trust them and so when
I started Spanx I instead of talking you
know at my customer I wanted to talk to
them and I made myself vulnerable so I
like I joked and said I used my own but
in the before and after picture but I
had felt like companies were operating
in this like we need to be perfect and
you need to see us as the authority and
you need me and that's how I'm gonna
sell you product and I was like hey like
I'm one of you like here's here's what's
happening here's what it does for me
this is why it works and it was just a
very different approach and I felt like
consumers became really connected and
really loyal and probably part of the
reason why Spanx as a brand didn't need
to advertise for six I mean we haven't
spent any money on advertising in 16
years because of a lot of it's word of
mouth from women sharing with other
women rule number 23 make the best
product the process of me cutting the
feet out of my pantyhose while trying to
get the prototype made before I launched
it was two years so there was a year
solid of me driving in North Carolina on
the weekends and at night or taking time
off from
work to go and work on the prototype get
it made I learned so many things that I
didn't know as a consumer it had never
dawned on me you know that men were
making all of our undergarments so I
learned very quickly that the industry
had been taking an average waistband
size between a small and an extra-large
and putting the same waistband on every
pair exactly that's nice that I said you
know that's not working we're really
uncomfortable and they were doing it to
cut cost in production so I immediately
change that in a Spanx waistband a size
small gets a small/medium gets a medium
and so on makes perfect sense right I
also realized that they had been putting
a tiny rubber cord inside the waist
bands that had been there forever well
we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so I
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing I learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out
his size by putting them on plastic
forms and they would all put it on a
plastic form they had different size
forms and they would stand back with
their clipboards and go yep that's the
size medium and I'd lean in and I go ask
her how she feels
so it's thanks we put our product on
women my mother my grandmother who's 90
my sister-in-law caste I mean all of my
friends the girls at Spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
Spanx garments and how they made you
feel remember 24 don't give up I went
online and looked up manufacturers that
made undergarments and hosiery type
products and I called them on the phone
and didn't get anywhere and eventually I
took a week off of work and drove around
North Carolina begging all of these men
ironically that we're making our
undergarments to help try to make this
new type of undergarment I went in
unannounced I had no appointment so you
can imagine how that went most of them
is corded me out and said good luck I
got a phone call about two weeks later
from one of the manufacturer owners and
he said Sara I have decided to help make
your crazy idea I ran it by my three
daughters at the dinner table and they
told me I should give you a shot rule
number 25 change your mindset banks
started way before I cut the feet out of
my pantyhose that's the sound bite in
the press that everybody's talked about
for almost 20 years but it actually
started fundamentally on when I was 16 I
worked on mind set for myself and I'm
such a believer in mind set is almost
everything and it just happened to be a
set of circumstances I was riding my
bike with one of my best friends at 16
and she was run over by a car and killed
in front of me and then a few months
later my dad left home and my parents
separated and ultimately got divorced
and when my dad moved out he came into
my bedroom and he handed me a cassette
tape series called how to be a No Limit
person by Wayne Dyer and he said sweetie
I wish I discovered this when I was your
age instead of the age of 40 and then he
moved out and so I started listening to
this how to be a No Limit person which
was talking about visualization law
action not caring about what other
people think about you the fear you know
not being consumed by the fear of
failure and it's just the clouds parted
for me and I thought you know I've spent
a lot of time being taught what to think
but no-one's really teaching me how to
think and at 16 I was so incredibly
important so in this digital platform
it's kind of passing on a lot of these
insights that deal with mindset that I
think is the real reason that Spanx
exists rule number 26 stand out from the
crowd the packaging what am I going to
do for the packaging I knew I thought as
a consumer I didn't know anything else
I'd never actually taken a marketing
class either in my life
but I knew as a consumer I was
frustrated I was going into the hosiery
departments and everything looked the
same
it was the same beige package or the
same way packaged with the same
half-naked woman that been on there for
thirty years and I couldn't tell what I
was buying so I said to myself I'm gonna
do this different I wanted to be my
favorite color red no one had ever done
red in the hosiery space before I wanted
to be bold stand out I knew that if I
got a chance to be on the shelf with no
money to advertise it had to jump out
and say I'm new I'm different try me so
I put three animated Illustrated cartoon
women on the package which had also
never been done before there had only
ever been photography on these hosiery
packages I was working on it every night
after work on my friend's computer she
had just finished graphic design school
so I would come home and we would sit
side by side and I was cutting out lips
and eyes and I was very you know decided
about how to make it design-wise I
wanted it to feel like you were buying a
present for yourself instead of a
commodity that we dreaded
rule number 27 redefined failure growing
up my dad used to encourage my brother
and me to fail so at the dinner table he
would actually ask us what did you fail
at this week and if we didn't have
something to tell him he would actually
be disappointed and I can remember
coming home from school and me like dad
dad I tried out for this and I was
horrible at he'd be like way to go and
high-five
and what it was such a gift what he was
doing I didn't realize that at the time
but he was redefining failure for me and
so failure became not about the outcome
but about not trying and so you know the
fear of failure as we all know it's
entrepreneurs is one of the greatest
fears in life it's one of the things
that stops us in our tracks and keeps us
from trying something and so I you know
I incorporate that in my philosophy at
Spanx we have we celebrate failures we
talk about them we have oops meetings
we're all announced the oops that I have
and sometimes we have fun with it we'll
even attach theme songs to our oops and
we'll play them in front of the whole
company but I think it's just so
important to try to get the people that
you work with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of I want to protect my job and feel
like I'm not safe if I make mistakes
rule number 28 ask questions many
aspiring entrepreneurs even in this room
struggle to find their initial idea how
do you constantly find ways to invent
new products and where does your
inspiration come from you know I I mean
I think of a lot of ideas of traffic
lights I think of them all the time in
different places and I think it's part
of just being hyper observant I I like
to find white space I pay attention to
what are things that haven't evolved and
why you know like there's certain things
in our society that updates itself and
changes and and you know constantly and
then there's certain things that it's
not and so I'll ask myself questions all
day every day it's just the way my brain
works like I could even be looking at a
table and be like why is the table like
that
when was the table first created is that
the actual best design for a table or
could there be something different and
you know what Spanx went into men's and
that was randomly how that happened was
because I got curious that the man's
undershirt was created in 1918 and no
one had paid any attention to it since
it was literally the same thing and so I
just you know talked to my brother and
my husband about it and their
undershirts that the neck stretched out
or they were boxy and bulky under
clothes and I thought oh I'm just gonna
add a little bit of like or to the
cotton undershirt for men and
so the neck won't stretch out I'm gonna
taper it in at the waist so ideas come
to me like that ideas I really up
clearly I love I am my assistant who's
my right hand lisa is she's been my
right hand for 16 years can attest to
this but I have 99 pages I don't know
why it's 99 but she told me the other
day it's 99 pages single-spaced types of
ideas one more idea so ie I think of
ideas constantly on airplanes in car you
know talking to somebody and I email it
to myself and then I just keep them and
logged them rule number 29 do your
research
okay so I've written the patent I'm
submitting it I have the prototype I'm
getting it almost perfect to where I
want it to be I got to come up with a
name so I had been writing down on scrap
pieces of paper for that entire year
really bad names in my car on a plane
you know pulling off the side of the
road and finally I narrowed down my
thinking on what I wanted to name my
invention by this I I recognized that
the two most recognized names in the
world at the time were Kodak and
coca-cola so I started playing with them
in my mind why are they the two most
recognized names in the world what do
they have in common and they both have a
significant K sound to them and I
actually had read that the man who
started Kodak liked the K sound so much
that he put the K in the beginning and
the end of the word and started playing
with letters in the alphabet to come up
with the word Kodak I also knew that you
know coca-cola had such a strong case
presence to it and I have a bunch of
friends that are stand-up comedians and
it's this just this weird trade secret
among comedians that the K sound will
make your audience laughs so it was
determined for good luck my invention
was going to have the K sound in it and
I added it I I decided okay once I
decided that I was clearer on my
thinking for the name it came to me
while sitting in traffic in Atlanta I
got very lucky I was sitting there and
just the word Spanx came across the
dashboard and at the very last second I
went home
and I knew it was right and I changed
the KS to an X at the last minute
because I had done research that made up
words do better for products than real
words do and they're also easier to
trademark I didn't tell one person the
name I got on USPTO govt which stands
for United States Patent and Trademark
Office gov which was my best friend at
the time I was always on that website I
did a search I entered my credit card
and for 50 or 300 dollars I hit Send and
I owned the name Spanx a month later I
got it in the mail room a 30 embrace
adversities the biggest hurdles for me
as a woman in business were also my
greatest strengths and that was being
underestimated many times in the journey
being underestimated made it harder for
me to get the men and the manufacturing
plans to take my idea seriously or to
even give me a chance but it was also a
real competitive advantage for me
growing the company I continued to
really embrace the being underestimated
as a woman and I've been able to stay
true to the feminine principles in
leadership and throughout growing Spanx
rule number 31 use humor to your
advantage I know that as part of the
Spanx training bootcamp one of the
mandatory learning modules is comedy
that every employee has to go through so
why is that important I want it I didn't
understand why why everybody was so
serious so I thought you know what I
don't subscribe to the fact that you
have to act serious to be taken
seriously and I like to laugh at myself
I you know I looked when I worked in
corporate America for a long time and
everybody was super uptight and super
serious there was no humor and there was
no levity and then everybody at like
5:00 o'clock became ragingly hilarious
it's like what what's going on like you
know and so the alcohol probably helped
you know but but anyway I I wanted to to
use humor and I loved to do that in the
workplace and yes we have a boot camp at
spanks a training boot camp when you
come on board and one of the modules is
doing stand-up comedy and I've used the
comedic stuff that I did in my marketing
I mean I wrote don't worry we've got
your butt covered right on my package
when I first started in 2000 which was
not very common to do especially taking
it to the Neiman Marcus to sell it
I named my company Spanx which was you
know made people laugh and believe it or
not it was very shocking at the time
that I named the company Spanx I
actually had people hang up on me often
I would call them and say hi I'm Sara
from Spanx and then they'd hang up and
I'd call back and I go I'm serious I'm a
real company and my company's called
spinning and they go oh I thought you
were prank calling me so and then you
know naming my products I broke into the
world's most boring category I mean can
we talk about shapewear who wants to
talk about shapewear and undergarments
but it was I named it power panties you
know I started naming all my products
and it made people laugh and it gave so
much energy and then all of a sudden you
had Gwyneth Paltrow and Julia Roberts
flashing their Spanx on red carpets and
saying I'm wearing Spanx like all these
celebrities and I think it's because I
chose to do humor and people wanted to
participate in that there was energy
around that so so I use it in every
aspect of of the marketing I use humor
to turn around a situation when I'm
bombing it it might give me a second
chance
when I cold called to sell fax machines
door-to-door for seven years I learned
very quickly that if I could make
somebody laugh or smile I'd get another
30 seconds before they'd slam the door
in my face there's just it's helps you
move through pain it's it's it's a
wonderful tool rule number 32 be smart
with your ideas when I first created the
idea for Spanx I didn't tell a soul for
one year and the reason I didn't do that
is because ideas are the most vulnerable
in their infancy and the moment you have
an idea it's human nature to turn to
your husband your wife your coworker and
tell them your idea and out of love and
concern oftentimes people will tell you
the two or three things that they think
maybe you should consider and it stops
people a lot of times often right in
their tracks so by not telling anybody
my idea for one year I left ego out of
it and I didn't have to spend the time
defending my idea or explaining my idea
I spent all the time pursuing my idea
rule number 33 believe in your idea I
had never taken a business class I'd
never worked in fashion or retail and I
had $5,000 in savings I just moved out
of my mother's house I was 27 years old
and I was probably dating a loser at the
time so there you have it
there I was and I you know wanted to
wear these pants I didn't know where to
go so I decided I've got to get this
made I went on the internet and I
started looking up hosiery mills and I
went to a website called Thomas registry
dot-com which lists all manufacturers in
the United States now it's called Thomas
net but they listed it for me and lucky
for me most of the hosiery manufacturers
are in North Carolina well I was in
Atlanta Georgia at the time so I started
picking up the phone and calling all
these manufacturers and introducing
myself over the phone and I I just I
couldn't get the right person on the
phone people kept transferring me around
I mean I imagine on the other end of the
line them saying you know there's a girl
online so she's gonna transform her own
butt like which department am I supposed
to send her to everyone kept either
hanging up on me saying no thanks it's
not a good idea so I believed in my own
idea enough though that I realized okay
I want to patent this I may be having
some difficulty right now getting
someone to help me make the idea but I
want to protect it so I went and looked
up on the internet martindale-hubbell
which is a website that lists attorneys
and they will tell you the ranking and
you know sort of the rating next to them
I started looking for a female patent
attorney in the state of Georgia I
couldn't find one so I called the
Georgia Chamber of Commerce and I
introduced myself said I'm looking for a
female patent attorney and they told me
that there actually was not a female
patent attorney in the state of Georgia
at the time so I said okay I got it I'm
gonna go describe this to a man and
we'll see what happens
and I went on the website I picked three
different law firms I cold call to each
law firm I put on my nicest suit from
selling fax machines that I had I had my
lucky red backpack that was with me the
entire journey of Spanx and I went and
met with them well they all quoted me
between three and five thousand dollars
to patent it and I had five thousand
dollars set aside and my savings to do
this so I decided to patent it myself
well the attorney that ended up helping
me at the very end of this process he
admitted to me that when I came to him
with the idea that he thought my idea
was so bad when I met with them but he
actually thought I had been sent by
candid camera
which completely makes perfect sense
because I was as I was sitting in the
room explaining it to him he kept
looking around the room and he later
said to me he said Sarah I really have
to tell you either thought you were sent
by candid camera or that I was being
pranked by some of my guy friends
because you know you whipped out the
pantyhose you're showing me the crotch
and where you cut these and how you're
gonna change the world and it's like I
wasn't used to that rule number 34
embarrass yourself I've said that you
try to go out of your way to embarrass
yourself on a regular basis why is that
well I'm I'm curious about the things
that hold power over us and one of the
big fears is fear of embarrassment we
all have that we have fear of failure so
I'm always working on these things that
I feel like might hold me back and so if
I embarrass myself then it loses its
power over me and especially if
embarrassing myself at times becomes the
goal then it feels like I don't know
it's like I'm playing my I'm like
playing my own head games with myself on
that but like one example of
embarrassing myself is you know I joined
Instagram and I joined F feel like I
might be the last one on the planet to
have joined it was about a year ago and
my team is like Joey and Instagram you
got to do it you got to put yourself out
there and I was nervous I wasn't sure
like I don't know and the day that I
joined I happened to be flying to New
York on business
and I was at the Atlanta Airport and so
I was like I'm gonna go around the
airport and personally ask people to
follow me
and it was so embarrassing and I was
mortified and I was embarrassing myself
and I posted the whole video it's like
my first post on Instagram is me because
I'm like how does this work how do you
get followers so I was around just you
know Jackson Hartfield Airport and I
even like stood up in the video I'm
filming myself and I make an
announcement at my gate I'm like excuse
me I'm Sara Blakely and I just joined
Instagram today will you follow me and
literally I go like that's not one
person looks about throwing I was like
thank you thank you I was going to ask
if it worked by that I made more
followers rule number 35 go against the
grain Blakeley has gone against the
grain from day one when Richard Branson
came out and announced that he was doing
a version of a reality show but he was
looking for 18 entrepreneurs that would
travel the world with him and do a
business challenge in different parts of
the world and I you know applied for it
and my lawyers begged me not to do it
begged me not to do it and I actually
took the contract it was a 27 page
contract and I emailed it to my dad
who's a lawyer and I said dad you know
I'm getting ready to sign this contract
can you help me look through it and give
me your thoughts and he all he wrote
back was dear Sara no sane person would
sign this love dad and you did it in all
you wrote so yes and you signed it I
signed it so my dad you know it's like
rolled his eyes there she goes rule
number 36 be persistent I call Neiman
Marcus around the corner of my apartment
in Atlanta and I said hi this is Sarah
I've got a product I want to come show
you and the lated kind of laughed and
said well we have a buying office and
that's in Dallas I don't know okay so I
hung up and I called and called the
buyer and from my cold calling days I
knew I'm not gonna leave a message I'm
gonna keep calling until this woman
answers the phone
so the second chance of their phone I
took a very deep breath I was so scared
and I said hi this is Sara Blakely and
I've invented something that's going to
completely change the way all of your
customers were closed and I'll fly to
see you if you'll give me five minutes
and she just kind of took a pause and
she goes well where do you live I said
Lanta she goes alright if you're willing
to fly here I'll give you 10 10 to 15
minutes so well jumped on a plane and I
went to the Neiman Marcus headquarters
before I went I was you know my few
friends I had my lucky red backpack they
stopped me in my tracks
I had my closest friends they go Sarah
please they were pleading with me please
don't bring that red backpack to the
Neiman Marcus headquarters I mean this
was my old backpack from college it was
just dirt II and you know they said do
anything you can't bring that red
backpack I mean if you need to go buy a
Prada bag return it the next day I mean
whatever you need to do but don't bring
that red backpack well I took a very
deep breath I said you know what this is
my good luck charm
I got to bring it so they're off I went
with the ziplock bag in the pack the
backpack the color copy of the packaging
I'm went to the Neiman Marcus
headquarters I'm sitting in front of
this buyer that was the most impeccably
dressed woman I'd ever seen in my life I
mean even her pen matched her outfit I
was just and I was shaking I had my red
backpack on the floor and I started
going into my spiel and I was I knew I
wasn't really making a ton of sense and
so halfway through it I go you know what
you just have to come with me the
bathroom excuse me I go I know I know
it's a little weird but just please come
with me to the bathroom I'm gonna do my
own before-and-after for you and then
you'll get it so we walk down the
hallway I mean in total silence I'm like
I can't believe this I go into this
stall I have on the white pants that
caused me to invent it I come out with
the Spanx on I turn around I just shown
her what it looked like without the
Spanx on and she took a step back and
she goes I get it
and then she goes it's brilliant and
then she said I'm gonna give you a shot
I'm gonna put you in seven stores roomba
37 be vulnerable I love the idea of
leaders and CEOs showing vulnerabilities
and showing the ups and downs and you
know I just I just don't really
subscribe in the feeling that I need to
put on any kind of a facade to be taken
seriously as a leader and so it's like
this is my life this is who I am I'm a
mom of four some days I'm working it out
some days I'm not and and I think that
that that's important rule number 38
visualize the idea a moment actually
happened before the idea because I had
been manifesting and visualizing a
different life for myself I was selling
fax machines door-to-door and I
specifically wrote down in my journal
that I wanted to invent something that I
could sell to millions of people and I
wanted the product to make people feel
good and one day in a frustrated moment
couldn't figure out what to wear under
my white pants like so many women I cut
the feet out of control top pantyhose
and threw them on under the pants and
they worked perfectly they they created
the perfect canvas they didn't leave any
lines like you know smooths everything
out but they rolled up my legs all night
and so I said you know this I got to
figure out how to make this stop
comfortably below the knee and create a
whole new type of undergarment for women
that's was in between traditional
underwear that we had to choose from and
the heavy-duty shapers girdles rule
number 39 fail growing up my dad used to
encourage my brother and me to
and he would ask us at the dinner table
what we had failed at that week and if
we didn't have something to tell him he
would actually be disappointed and I
didn't realize that at the time but he
was just redefining failure for me
failure became about not trying not the
outcome going through life the only
failure that I ever feel that I've had
is if I don't try so that was a real
gift that he gave me
rule number 40 grow organically I just
wanted Oprah I had this product I felt
that it was a you know I was on to
something I needed to build a team I
needed some help so my boyfriend who was
the healthcare consultant he left his
job and he started helping me do all the
fulfillment
he said you got you you know I'd send my
trucks pulling up twice a week to my
apartment in Atlanta and I was doing all
the shipping at night and he really
started helping me do the fulfillment
and we were in the back room we ended I
ended up starting the headquarters in my
best friend's bedroom she had moved out
and I we set up two cardboard tables in
the beginning and people used to call
and say I need to speak to shipping and
handling and we'd always say please hold
buy transfer you
then I then I that I went for a walk
with a friend to get a bagel and I'd
given her one of my prototypes and the
entire walk to get the bagel she all she
did was tell me how much she loved it by
the end of the walk I looked at her and
I said do you want to be my head of PR
she's like well I don't know anything
about PR I go I don't either I've been
calling these radio stations and
magazines and circling people's names
and newspapers and I think you could do
it just as good as I could if not better
you seem to really love the product so
she immediately came on board and
started doing that and then the third
person that joined my team was someone
that I was looking for an assistant
because at that time I was doing
everything and also trying to coordinate
my travel and it just got so crazy so
quickly so this woman Joo didya who had
been an interior designer came on board
to be my assistant and after two weeks
in my apartment I came home one day and
I looked at her and I said do you want
to be my head of product development she
looked at me she goes I don't know
anything about pantyhose or shapers I go
I don't either
it's perfect rule number 41 hustle I
feel like hustle is the willingness to
work really really hard and then also
your willingness to get the job done
like kind of navigating and doing what
it takes and and so I yeah I've there's
so much about my journey where I was
like I am NOT gonna let the outcome or
my success be contingent on other people
as much as I can control it help it
navigate it I'm going to so so yeah in
the beginning especially still now I
mean obviously I'm hustling I'm like at
this where I am now and I'm running
around the airport asking people to
follow me on Instagram you know I just
feel like it's innate in me also to a
degree but the in the beginning like
there's a few examples that come to mind
you mention that I paid my I called my
friends and ask them to go buy Spanx and
I wrote everybody checks and sent them a
check because I needed to drive momentum
and I had no money to advertise so I'm
like this products gonna sit on the
shelf so I need
to get people to go in and buy it I also
when I went into the stores I realized
very quickly that my product was in the
sleepiest part of the department store
it was back in the corner and nobody was
going there so then I immediately went
to a Target and I bought envelope
dividing dividers that you put on your
home death and I ran around Neiman
Marcus and put them at every register
and I put Spanx in them and then I
walked away and Neiman's has like
impeccable visual rules and regulations
and and I did that because I had to get
my product out of the department and
because I did that women in shoes
started buying Spanx and women in
contemporary and and those decisions
made such a big difference and by the
time somebody figured out that nobody
else had approved it because I you know
everybody thought somebody else approved
it it was so successful that the head of
Neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it rule number
42 ensure your success I cold called
Neiman Saks Nordstrom Bloomingdale's QVC
I was out on the road and I think a lot
of entrepreneurs make the mistake they
think once you get the order you're
golden and that couldn't be any farther
from the truth
once you get the order that's when the
real work starts I was absolutely
determined to ensure my own success and
I think that's what it takes I didn't
want my success to be contingent on
anyone else having to sell this so I hit
the ground running and I went from
department store to department store and
I would do morning rallies at the store
where I would gather people around well
the store manager said Sarah you know
you can do it with the hosiery
associates well I'd travel all the way
to Arizona and there'd be three hosiery
associates so I quickly was like I got
to get the whole store this morning
rally so I would go into the entrance
before the store open like a Neiman's or
a Saks or a Bloomingdale's and I would
run around and introduce myself to every
employees setting up their station and
I'd say hi I'm Sarah and I would try to
convince them that it would be worth
their time to come see my morning
meeting and I got everybody there I had
taken the Oprah clip and the little bit
of local press I'd I'd received and put
it on a video and did that in my morning
rally and it was such an important thing
that I was doing I inadvertently was
building a Salesforce that wasn't on my
payroll and they all across the country
became my biggest advocates for the
product and started selling it on behalf
of Spanx and me rule number 43 delegate
your weaknesses what's the best advice
that you've received someone told me
that what you delegate is 80% as good as
you would have done it yourself let it
go
I took inventory of what am I good at
what am I not good at what do I you know
enjoy and don't enjoy they're usually
the very thing I really like I was very
clear in the first year I was not good
at shipping and handling and I wasn't
good at you know so many different
things about managing the inventory but
I loved inventing the next idea I loved
the brand I loved the way that I was
communicating with consumers so being
able to free yourself up to do what you
do best and let the people who do the
other aspects do s do it
rule number 44 don't be afraid to fail
and I think companies if you can create
a culture where they're not terrified to
fail or make a mistake then you're gonna
you're gonna be a highly productive and
more innovative culture so having people
feel free to laugh at themselves and
watching me as their leader laugh at
myself I have oops meetings at spanks
where we get up and I tell them what I
messed up at or a mistake that I made
and I usually tell a funny story about
it and I encourage everybody else in the
company to stand up and say that and
then share and make it a funny story and
so I think that that helps rule number
45 be resourceful when Spanx started I
got to set the stage a little bit for
you there were no self there were no
excuse me blackberries no one had ever
heard of an iPhone or an iPod before I
mean the Kardashians were in like the
5th grade
and MapQuest was just getting started so
half the time I was on my computer in
the hotel that I was staying at and
trying to MapQuest my next location and
it was a really crazy time as I'm
driving all around I you know I'm
thinking to myself actually I remember
this one time in Chicago I'd spent so
much time alone on the road I did an
event at the Neiman Marcus outside of
Evanston I believe it was at in oak
brook or Northbrook and I spent the
whole day promoting lifting up my pant
leg and turning and shaking my butt for
everyone in the entrance and that's you
know I'd been setting up these tables
and moving them farther and farther out
of the hosiery Department to the point
where they were in the entrance of
Neiman Marcus I mean people would walk
it I go hi I'm Sarah and I would flash
them my bud and you know I was trying
everything I put Donuts on the table I
was like have a doughnut and some Spanx
rule number 46 be persistent every time
I heard a no I would just keep going
once she finally got a yes came the
first sound the very first place I
called was Neiman Marcus and I just kept
calling the buyer on the phone until she
picked up I just said I'm Sara Blakely I
invented a product that is going to
change the way your customers wear
clothes please give me 15 minutes of
your time and I said I will fly to
Dallas and she said if you're willing to
fly here I will give you 15 minutes so I
booked a flight and halfway through
telling her about the product I mean
everything about her was perfect right
her belt matched her pen that matched
her shoes I was like highly intimidated
sitting there with my my old backpack
and I said you know what I think you
just need to come with me to the
bathroom in mid pitch and she went
excuse me and I said yes just just come
with me to the bathroom I'm gonna show
you what my product can do first hand
rule number 47 take control of your life
a lot of people think that Spanx started
when I cut the feet out of my pantyhose
but actually it started long before that
it started when I was selling fax
machines door-to-door and getting my
cart business card ripped up in my face
being escorted out of buildings all day
every day that I woke up one day and
just thought I'm in the wrong movie like
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene director like call the
producer and I got out a piece of paper
and I wrote down what am I good at
and the only thing in the good column
was sales and I thought okay what am I
going to do with that and I ended up
writing in my journal I'm going to
invent a product and sell it to millions
of people that will make them feel good
and then I asked the universe for an
idea and I was very specific and it took
two years and I only cut the feet out of
my pantyhose one time and I was not
gonna squander any idea the universe
gave me because I hadn't really asked
for it and then the minute I cut the
feet out I started trying to make it
I started looking up holds manufacturers
on the internet this is before Ali Baba
wasn't it yes rule number 48
differentiate yourself I've got to
differentiate yourself I always ask
myself why am i different how am i
different and I think it's very
important to be I call them the three
C's but clear concise and confident you
have to be able to describe it in a
minute or less make it so clear the
customer really wants to make smart
decisions and they really want us to
make it easy for them so I always say
make somebody feel the pain or if it's
not the pain which means the problem on
why you did what you did or why you're
creating what you create then explain to
them your uniqueness and then right
after that you've got to give them the
solution very quickly and then take it
through and say why you're the best I
mean very quickly explain to them in
just a few seconds why you're the best
option and I find that very very helpful
so in everything I do ask myself why am
i different rule number 49 deal with
rejections I call myself a girl who
really likes to challenge herself to do
things that scare her to auditioning at
Disney World I ended up at Disney World
because I failed the LSAT and I felt
very sad that I most likely wasn't gonna
be heading off to law school I am a
terrible test taker so I did what my
parents said of course would be the most
natural thing to do and I got in my car
and drove to Disney World and tried out
to be goofy and just to add you know
insult to injury I'm too short to be
goofy so I just failed the LSAT I went
through all the auditions to become a
character and you have to be five eight
to be goofy and I'm five six so I'm the
height of a
yes so they wanted to make me a chipmunk
and rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is just be who
you are what keeps you so unbelievably
grounded amid all your resounding
success
I feel like success just makes you more
of who you already were
I feel like money and success just does
that so it's like it holds a magnifying
glass up to who you are people you know
people always ask me that and I'm like I
don't know who else to be I mean I am
Who I am so the money the success and so
I like to say if you were a jerk before
you got really successful and a lot of
money you should you become a bigger
jerk usually and if you were insecure
you'll become more insecure if you were
nice you'd become nicer if you were
generous you'll become more generous
it's literally just a magnifying glass
now I have a special bonus clip from
Sarah on how to have a mission that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that is that where the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go question number one how can you be
more vulnerable in your business and
life number two what's the adversity
you're facing that you need to embrace
and number three what's the weakness you
have that you need to hire for and if
you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos anymore we do something after
watching them give me a hashtag believe
down the comments make that promise to
yourself and then get to work what role
do you hope the Sara Blakely foundation
will play in the empowerment of women
well I mean my ultimate goal is that the
male and female energy on the planet
becomes balanced so I feel like that's a
snap oh alright well good that one
person who agrees with me yeah so anyway
the male and female energy on the planet
more balanced and the reason why I say
energy I mentioned earlier is that we
all have the male and the female energy
inside of us and I feel like the
feminine has been pretty squashed for a
long time on our planet and it's not
serving the greater whole so what can I
do in my short lifetime to elevate the
feminine and
and that's what the foundation is
focused on in how can I help be
elevating and supporting that and I take
my opportunity as a woman in this
country so seriously and I think part of
the reason that I do is because I got to
watch my mom and my grandmothers and
their lack of options and that was
really hard and so you know we've been
on the planet for thousands of years or
millions of years depending on who you
ask and what you think but the bottom
line is my mom is only 22 years older
than me and my mom had about three or
four options only afforded to her
because she was a woman so in the grand
scheme of life and how long we've been
on earth I'm like I made it by 22 years
like what you're kidding me so I feel
like a lot of my courage and you know
I'm scared of a lot of things I mean I'm
afraid to fly I'm afraid of heights like
I've got all kinds of things but I feel
like where I get my courage is that
Retta knowing and thinking about I'm a
woman born in the right place at the
right time I don't want to squander that
if you want to see the top ten I did on
Sarah's husband Jesse it's let's check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there now fear is a really powerful
thing but when you surrender and say I'm
not scared of fear it's unbelievably